hi I'm Megan of people and I'm Amir
Abbas and we're both part of the Google
cloud platform team in origin obviously
make cloud easier and we do this by
creating demos posting them on github
doing presentations as a matter of fact
we're here at Q con 2019 in San Diego we
had a great presentation about virtual
machines as part of your kubernetes
ecosystem now I know what you're all
thinking what are we talking about
virtual machines at acute con the harsh
reality is that most customers we talk
to all have virtual machines running in
their environment these could be
databases legacy stateful applications
even if they're migrating their
applications over to kubernetes they
need a way to talk to these applications
and for that we're using Sto which is a
service mess technology that Megan is
going to talk a little bit more about so
the way to appropriate a virtual machine
into an SEO service mashup
running on kubernetes it's really easy
all you have to do is install the sco
sidecar proxy and the assume no agent on
the virtual machine and then configure
it to go home to still running on the
cluster once you do that it's really
easy to see all of the metrics and logs
for both pod and VM workloads in one
place and it's really easy to apply
policies like pro base access control
and encryption on both environments if
you're interested in learning more check
out bitly slash life outside the cluster
Thanks thank you
[Music]